[Music]
it's the annual eating of the herring in
Finland but for one week in October
people come here to downtown Helsinki to
gorge on the freshest of fish and other
delicious smoky treats they jockey for
position prepare Instagram posts and
enjoy some Toki and inspired folk
[Music]
[Music]
yes Jesus you may have heard life is
good for the Finns their kids are
smarter than yours their health system
is healthier than yours and my god their
parks are parking our than yours these
fins also eat really well on a square
plate there is some old feta
lightly smoked pork and boiled garlic
emotional Here I am at your
run-of-the-mill fast casual joint
popping some bubbly and gobbling up a
ham and cheese roll followed by a NASA
inspired marshmallow made out of beets
crazy but the future of food for Finland
and the rest of the world may be here
where protein is grown in a vat overseen
by the finished version of Walter White
[Music]
this is solar foods with its
headquarters in Espoo on the outskirts
of Helsinki
[Music]
we make food out of thin air using just
electricity water co2 and some minerals
as the main ingredients have you ever
seen Breaking Bad yeah is there anything
else we should know that happens in here
this is pretty legal okay until the
pivot to full-blown meth labs needed
solar foods is focusing on making
protein and other nutrients with as
little water and other resources as
possible no cows no soy fields just
bacteria being fed in a tub by Nature
and harvested by lab coat wearing
laborers in essence what we are making
is ingredient for different food
products so tofu yogurt breakfast bars
or any meal that one could think of
solar foods grabs co2 from the fresh
finish air and hydrogen produced via
solar panels and uses this fuel to feed
a microorganism discovered by scientists
in Finnish soil the bacteria is then fed
a cocktail of water and a secret blend
of elements such as iron sulfur and
calcium this slurry of goodness is then
dried to produce a powder that's 65%
protein with a few fatty acids and carbs
making up the rest this is the end
product this yellowish powder protein
powder and then this is just the liquid
form of that and how long is the drying
process take it takes about the day to
dry one kilo solar Foods calls this
stuff so lame powder is it vetted by the
FDA yet no is it safe for consumption
I'm told yes and since I'm the guinea
pig for a technology show my gut is your
gut this is my personal vegan pancake
recipe it's like the regular ingredients
for pancakes pretty much except we're
replacing eggs with with silane powder
that's the magic moment alright Anka's
are better yeah you're a pro do you want
to try it that's right this is this is
like the pancake of the future I've
never eaten pancakes grown in a
laboratory before it's a delicious
pancake those dudes may cook a mean
protein powder but the true star of the
finished healthier food movement is this
one Maya it Conan the co-founder and CEO
of golden green golden green makes a
vegetable based meat replacement called
pulled oats everyone I met in Finland
eats it it's in the grocery stores in a
variety of flavors and you can even get
it at Taco Bell inside the vegan burrito
it's a thing a brown chunky thing Maya
and I met in a former Nokia Cable
Factory where else to try out some pull
notes you're not trying to mimic meat
necessarily at all right you're just
trying to make something that's sort of
delicious that's made from oats
that's exactly through and and it might
be the final application is mimicking
you know because when you make a burger
it needs to be something that feels like
a burger but what actually doesn't mimic
is the incremental is that ingredient
least we actually want to make sure that
you have few things and they're really
healthy and really clean label and
everything's based on that what are the
big advantages of us it's not meat sir I
mean what you have is it's not
originally it's like marvelous it has so
good health benefits for your heart
health and digestion and blood sugar and
it's like medicine you know thanks so
much it's like a curry hmm
it's delicious I mean I read this idea
anyway so when we got started we didn't
have a plan to sell in Finland this was
like two years ago this is 2016 but we
thought let's just aim to test it in a
couple of grocery stores then it was so
funny because what happened was that
people could entirely crazy although all
the newspapers started to call us and
all the buyers start to call us so that
was like okay we are gonna sell this in
Finland you know and actually the market
grew like 700 percent during that year
[Music]
unlike just about every other company in
Finland golden greens headquarters are
not in a former Nokia building they're
in a former bra factory and it's
elevator is real and spectacular this is
where pull doubts come to life so these
are the basic ingredients yes actually
this is oat flour then we have a fava
bean flour then we also have a yellow
pea pea protein but that's about it
okay and then the magic the secret is
how you blend this all together
absolutely yes
so we first make like a dry material
base of these ingredients okay then we
start moisturizing and baking it and it
becomes something like this okay so this
this goes through like a machine and the
machine in the process that's all top
secret nobody gets to see that but I am
allowed to see this a brand new venture
for gold and green and it's sizzling
salty and pork ish it's something that
can be made to to replace like chicken
Maya refuses to call it bacon but it's
pretty much bacon and it might even be
good I mean that's delicious got all the
like nice salty fatty kind of feel to it
yeah I like this a lot
[Music]
and now thanks to a brave volunteer from
golden-green a better living through
Finland interlude that will come as
quite the shock to my American friends I
present to you the baby a mother and a
baby box this is something that the
government sends to every mother yes or
you can like choose you maybe don't want
this and you can take the money
so it's 170 euros the box is this meant
to be like a crib yes it is like a safe
and comfy place to sleep but also in
this box there is 63 items okay
no there is like the first baby book you
get all these clothes all the clothes in
Finland it is quite common that you
leave the child outside to take a nap
okay so that's why we need a lot of
clothes
so the babies warm they sleep outside
yes that's all seasons or just what it's
the wintertime why do they sleep outside
I think it's it's good for you how much
maternity leave do you get in Finland
nine months so in the Box there's also
the hygiene things it is for the baby
and also for adults
you get like a man you guys think of
everything yes I think I know that one
day the American dream will also include
state-provided Lube right right
[Music]
by now you're probably thinking these
fins are godless vegan socialists who
have an unnatural amount of concern for
nature and general well-being this is
probably even true they also have a
thing for relaxing in the glorious
outdoors like this open-air Oasis on
Helsinki's waterfront I give to you the
Alice pools
[Music]
steamed to perfection and refreshed and
frozen by the Baltic Sea I returned to
the mean streets of Helsinki to find out
the other ways in which the finns are
better than the rest of us which brought
me here to a start-up and Suvi jaime she
is the co-founder and CEO of sulla pact
and they want to replace plastic with
this what is important in our material
it's micro plastic free eventually
plastic degrades into micro plastic
particles and they say hundreds of years
or even permanently in the nature but we
have created almost all the benefits of
plastic without the plastic waste
problem the big idea here is to take
waste wood mash it up with some plant
matter and create a substance that can
be molded into all kinds of things from
straws to containers to coat hangers
then when you're done with the objects
you ditch them and they gracefully turn
back into plant matter we make our
materials out of wood and natural
binders and these plant-based binders
they degrade so they can be eaten by
natural occurring microorganisms ok so
no micro plastics left
Soula pack is pulled in some big-name
investors including Chanel and it
started making its products in factories
all over the world
here are their straws coming to life in
a factory in st. Louis and unlike paper
straws these wooden things actually work
so with the straw how long would this
last compare like a paper straw when I
put it in a drink every second it's
usually melted by the end of the drink
well the criteria is that if you change
the drink you have to be able to use
this one straw so the whole evening
you're able to drink mojitos Frances
which is my favorite drink what is one
straw we need new initiatives to make
these micro plastics free materials
because there is so much plastic out
there you with one company with one
material you can't solve it all of
course if experimental protein then
plastic induced shame is all too much
for you have no fear the fins still have
you covered here at a traditional
finished restaurant a very nice set of
ladies will set you up with finished gin
scrumptious reindeer moose a ski loaded
with shots and one hell of a bear pie
[Music]
but that's enough about fins in their
food next time on hello world some good
old-fashioned hardtack and a visit to a
sauna with a movie star
it's really hard to not be honest when
you're so exposed and so bare
[Music]
you